oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
reed man depuis des milliers d'années la
vie de la guadeloupe la basse terre et
son volcan actif de la soufrière chef
d'orchestre de l'archipel cet ordre
qu'annick incroyablement fertile et
riche en bienfaits profitent autant à la
santé des plantes qu'à celle des hommes
[Musique]
delon souffre et dont les ressources et
les vertus semble infinie aux plantes
cultivées parfois transformer en
médicament
l'archipel est un condensé de toute la
biodiversité des antilles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur cette terre tout en relief les
hommes respectent et entretiennent
cadeaux miraculeux que la nature leur
laisse à disposition
[Musique]
assister au réveil de la soufrière n'est
jamais une garantie
la vieille dame comme on l'appelle ici
s'entoure dp nuage et se découvre
rarement mais ce matin elle se dévoile
dans toute sa splendeur et sa puissance
sous les premiers rayons du soleil un
spectacle rare exceptionnel
[Musique]
à 1467 mètres d'altitude plus dôme de la
soufrière domine l'archipel des antilles
[Musique]
s'il faut choisir son jour il faut
également s'armer de courage pour
accéder au sommet
moi
[Musique]
ouais ouais je suis maintenant deux
heures d'escaladé à travers les rochers
des cailloux par contre le spectacle les
boas et a toujours ses ces nuages acquis
et découvre le paysage a pas duré
longtemps parce que c'est l'un des
endroits rue peut le plus sur la planète
12 mètres d'eau par an c'est très
arrosée et fait qu'on a des nuages c'est
la forêt du genre et c'est la végétation
de nuages on est vraiment au sommet dans
ce bateau-là bien vers bienne est prêt
mais ça vaut le coup raiola
à
ces master naïf la côte sous le vent
la mer à deux kilomètres km à vol
d'oiseau
c'est dingue on est sur le 3d petites
antilles au centre de la caraïbe
insulaire
[Musique]
à
félix lurel est un botaniste écologiste
réputé en guadeloupe séduit dès son plus
jeune âge par les pouvoirs
extraordinaires de dame nature
il consacre sa vie à recenser les
plantes oubliées qui font la richesse de
son île
et comme beaucoup de guadeloupéens il
voue un culte particulier à l'imposante
soufrière
[Musique]
ah oui le voilage cratère ça c'est la
matrice la matrice de la guadeloupe sont
la matrice du volcan ah oui
toute cette vapeur qui s'échappe de ce
cratère selon qui la vapeur d'eau avec
de gaz à wes et lola qui rencontre la
route chaude et puis l'eau va rejaillir
comme ça comme des geysers c'est
magnifique à voir avant le port comme ça
fumait en permanence là on a
l'impression d'être sur une autre
planète
c'est notre planète
c'est de là que
la guadeloupe est sorti et quoi on sort
de nulle part au milieu de la mer d'aral
caen puis voilà c'est vraiment un autre
maire c'est notre grande dame et c'est
ce que je dis moi c'est là la source de
vie c'est la matrice de la guadeloupe et
le respect les origines de la vie la vie
insulaire
alors celui là qui est sourd on sent que
ça gronde que c'est le coeur de la terre
c'est merveilleux mais c'est surtout
très impressionnant quand ici c'est très
particulier c'est pas une cocotte-minute
c'est une grosse chaudière quoi cette
gigantesque pas bouillotte enfin pouvoir
qui va chauffer c'est de l'eau en
ébullition enfin c'est un bruit sont
qu'on connaît bien
on entend aussi dans les séismes
celui-là quand il est en éruption
[Musique]
voilà on le connaît ce bruit et on le
retrouve un peu plus bas dans le
carnaval on va le retrouver quand on
veut faire du bouilh fait le plus de vos
le point
la terre respire et nous renvoie au
commencement du monde quand les paysages
se formait quand la terre se soulever
dans des explosions de cendres et de
magma le souffle chaud
l'odeur de soufre par endroits
suffocante rappelle le danger mais le
volcan est aussi une formidable source
de vie des minéraux sources chaudes
reconnues pour leurs vertus
thérapeutiques
le volcan dispense autour de lui c'est
bien fait depuis des siècles alors là
comme ça des gaz qui vont sortir des
microfissures ouais ça sent l'oeuf
pourri la des fissures avec des gaz qui
sortent chaud voilà c'est chaud etc ça
qu'on fait aussi de la géothermie
électricité on voit ces gaz qui vont
s'échapper comme ça dans le massif dans
des fissures de microfissures
on la surnomme la vieille dame alors que
c'est un tout jeune volcan dernier 17
complexe volcanique de la guadeloupe
c'est également le seul encore actifs le
tome actuel est le vestige de la
dernière éruption magmatique daté de 15
130 surveiller au quotidien il est
rempli d'eau bouillante et la principale
menace ce sont les éruptions phréatiques
la dernière s'est produite en 1976
parfois aussi il peut être en colère
et quand il est en colère et parfois
inquiétants quant à gond trop fort un
don qu'elle est suivie ce volcan il est
vraiment suivi façon très minutieuse et
en 76
je me rappelle très bien on a une
manifestation phréatiques avec des
cendres des pluies de cendres des
éruptions de dos de gaz de cendres des
projections de roche et là on descendait
tout gris on avait de la cendre sous les
paupières a les cheveux on était tout
gris comme des fantômes et on a dû
évacuer la zone
pendant plusieurs mois donc on a dû même
temps on n'a pas le temps de fermer des
portes voilà les gens sont partis en
descendent des remontées dans des
voitures qui pouvait encore
circulez j'étais vraiment en plus puis
voilà on n'a pas eu trop de dégâts
matériels non il n'y a pas eu des rup
sion l'explosion
quelques notes de couleurs et gueye ce
paysage lunaire et minérales au milieu
des fumerolles qui jaillissent des
entrailles de la terre
une végétation a su trouver sa place ah
oui cette végétation là c'est anna
montagne ici elles sont rouges
c'est une plante très spécialisés
vraiment un pour rester dans des
conditions aussi contraignantes de
chaleur de gaz qui peut être toxique et
d'ailleurs on voit bien qu'à pas
beaucoup d'espèces qu'il existe ici
c'est vraiment un intérêt scientifique
extraordinaire restait dense et chaleur
la pouvoir pousser ce phénoménal comment
une plante activé j'étale comme ça
arrive à résister à ces conditions
regarde là ses petits doigts c'est
d'hélico pod magnifique c'est soyeux
très beau tableau des fougères ah ouais
on en a à peu près 300 fougères comme ça
en guadeloupe à des fougères 300
des plantes à fleurs tu es montagne mais
tu plantes à fleurs près de 2000 plantes
à fleurs en guadeloupe a trouvé tout 200
orchidées belle biodiversité en tout cas
c'est vraiment magnifique là c'est ce
tableau c'est une atmosphère tout à fait
spécial c'est vraiment une ambiance très
particulière
il ya des anars où j'ai des ananas
jeunes se fait c'est exceptionnel quoi
il faut venir à la soufrière en
guadeloupe pour voir ça non mais si on
manque de mots c'est ça la savane
d'altitude c'est ça la végétation très
particulière d'altitude
y a pas d'arbres ici c'est souvent dans
les nuages avec une forte nébulosité il
faut vraiment être costaud pour tous il
faut mettre adapté
donc respect quoi pas réalisé
ouais cowboys à voir quoi
[Musique]
au sommet à 1467 m les émissions
gazeuses ne permettent pas la végétation
de s'épanouir pleinement
et
mais dès qu'on commence à redescendre la
flore évolué
palier par palier mètre par mètre de
nouvelles variétés de végétaux
apparaissent ici débute la forêt
d'altitude dans cette zone l'air saturé
d'eau gênent la respiration des plantes
comme si elle retenait son souffle
la végétation pousse lentement les
arbres ils sont peu nombreux
la priorité à la défunte ur
à la mosson
et après faire du bien
[Musique]
tiens on retrouve ici là la grande
faille la grande pompe la revoir et puis
voilà on a on est plus bas on n'est plus
dans les nuages
ici il ya même déjà des fougères
arborescentes on voit une végétation un
peu plus four est un arbuste il est donc
on voit l'étagement de végétation où
c'était une vraie savane et maintenant
on a une végétation arbustive avec des
éléments qui peut faire trois mètres 4 m
on est déjà dans cent mètres plus loin
de dénivelé au moins ah oui c'est très
bien et là on voit un beau four et
demande le montagne avec des feuilles
très coriace très large
ça dépasse pas 3 mètres 4 mètres maximum
la transition est très nette et là on
est dans un fourré un fourré aux voiles
à l'altitude avec ce monde le sait
impénétrables c'est complètement plein
de petites branches partout là on est
vraiment dans le fourré au rebut stif au
certaines plantes qui poussent ici en
abondance sont utilisés dans la vie
courante
ah le petit à marennes montagne ce très
joli ça de toutes petites feuilles pas
marrer montagne je retrouve la sphaigne
la lie à l'humidité partout est de l'eau
et moi ce serait con mais aussi pour les
couches là dans les couches de bébés
dauphins s'absentera garde l'eau c'est
vraiment des réservoirs d'eau toute une
palette de couleurs dégradé de jaune
orange de verre ah oui oui je suis
émerveillé
chaque fois que je passe là
[Musique]
la soufrière a des vertus thérapeutiques
sous terre en se rapprochant du magma le
se réchauffe pour ensuite se déverser
dans de nombreux bassins aux quatre
coins de l'île
[Musique]
en contrebas du volcan les bains jaunes
offre une eau souffrait à près de 28
degrés aux randonneurs qui redescend du
sommet
[Musique]
à
au nord de l'île à sofia des douches
plus secrètes sont particulièrement
prisés des gaules de peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis ma naissance j'ai toujours
entendu ça fait du bien de temps en
temps je viens pour nommer
ça c'est la première de l'année que le
suivre tout le monde connaissait de chez
nous c'est bon pour la peau pour pour le
sang le fait d'être là des points de la
douche en avant dix ans la réputation de
fait et en voilà eh ben je me sens bien
en atteste ce phénomène ce point d'eau
est apparue lors du tremblement de terre
de 1843
on vient ici pour faire le plein
d'énergie et même pour se soigner
[Applaudissements]
je viens régulièrement ici me ressourcer
régénéré c'est un endroit est un peu
magique pour moi très peu de pollution
delà de la nature pure des verts tout
est calme et en profitent
voilà c'est gratuit
on peut profiter également de l'air vous
voyez qu ici on ressent un petit peu ces
terres souffre aimé qu'on ressent encore
plus en allant la soufrière
on croise un peu tout le monde lui dire
des gens du quartier des gens de la
ville gens qui viennent un peu de
partout en wallonie parce que tout le
monde connaît cette source et beaucoup
viennent se baigner profiter de la
qualité de cette eau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
reconnu pour dégager des voies
respiratoires le soufre a aussi des
vertus dermatologiques
c'est un constituant essentiel de la
peau et des cheveux
certains préfèrent s'accorder un moment
de relaxation chez eux et font le plein
de cette eau qui guérit
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'habitude de me baigner aubin
souffrait et ensuite d'aller à la
chapelle le souffle ailleurs ça me
permet de me relaxer spirituellement de
me purifier on va dire ça comme ça et
après donc ça m'a mis en disposition
pour aller comme ati prière à la
chapelle
quand j'ai des enfants je lirai savait
qu après la tâche pour qu'elles puissent
dormir avec pendant la nuit présent dans
l'air l'eau et la terre
le soufre à mille vertus ajoutée ou
minéraux volcaniques
il rompt les sols incroyablement fertile
je suis sur ses propriétés
si on est arrivé comme par hasard mais
on est tombé sur la cité qui est
agréable qui est très bien situé dans
cette fois bien ici on a été magnifique
face à nous il ya la mer
la meilleure l'étendue jusqu'à
montserrat les stars trop de bas
ici c'est une terre volcanique où on
peut tout planter c'est intel qui est
très perméable
on a des gosses pris deux ou après on
peut la cultiver traqué
la propriété de clotaire à mme élise est
idéalement situé sur les pentes du
volcan
[Musique]
tous
à
en toile et les toupies là vous nous
avons
la culture des mélodies marmoucha
s'adonnent les fleurs chaque leurs seins
fruits noirs aujourd'hui on devait être
henri got malheureusement maria ce
chrono ouaga a rasé et nous a laissé
quelques liens on a fait aux repas au
tiers les liens waouh c est ça l indice
a commencé à donner les premiers fruits
il n'y avait pas le feu dans les hommes
dans les tubes rock et le attelle et il
y avait pas de piège tout a été brûlé
ce que nous voyons aujourd'hui c'est ce
qui a poussé après le passé ça aurait
démarré assez vite dans notre travail
parce que on a commencé à couper
les branches pour créer les passages la
nature nous a accompagnés bien entendu
puisque les citrons au frais au moins
deux mois après le passage du cyclone
oli
[Musique]
sans les ravages des douze ouragans irma
et maria en 2017
clotaire serait un homme heureux par
respect pour cette terre il n'utilise
aucun engrais chimiques pour faire
repartir l'activité au plus vite
primé sur le curcuma le gingembre et les
lumineuses
[Musique]
or doc est aussi en droit cette année à
une bonne le coton aux cuma toute cette
bande là et planter un clou du mans
jusqu'en bas
l'argument c'est une plainte qui a été
très très à consommer et ça va être
consommé beaucoup plus ici en guadeloupe
et a beaucoup de collègues qui en
cultive moi j'étais parmi les premiers
bains jadis qui lie les plans et vend
même pas les pleins feux et a
suffisamment un document du gingembre
des poids et tout ce qui s'ensuit qui
arrivent sur notre marché pour nous et
la population au lieu que ce et d'autres
qui nous les amènent ici
les bagarres et si ça c'est pas car il a
cassé jeunes comme ceux là on les mange
salade et c'est un coupe faim si vous
n'avez pas manger le matin puis pendant
quelques duels bien ça vous allez
maintenant mal malgré ses bons coups en
pleine maturité tubes comme les lillois
sont seuls ils oiseaux le font avec moi
aussi la bm a quelques regrets mais
c'est cool mais tu cominois c'est bon ah
bon
13h que terre seront au marché des
mornes à baillif a rendez vous
hebdomadaire incontournable dont il est
le président achalandée avec le minimum
qu'on comme aliens réalisé commença à
leurs côtés depuis mai au coeur
normalement à cette période là ça cycle
des marchés est bien quand c'est une
grande famille je suis largué décoller
et amiens ou montrer que la solidarité
c'est bien
la madone qui serait bâti sur le marché
des mornes regroupe une vingtaine
d'agriculteurs
tous vantent ici des fruits et légumes
de la soufrière
[Musique]
avant moi le besoin alors points de juin
ok
là
pour la météo
après
pour toi
mais je vais bien
les
buzet d'armé
[Musique]
la passion
d
[Musique]
quel est sûre tomates
by zahia de retour sur les haies val
après le passage des ouragans que les
laiteries les cultures tout à repousser
très vite sur la terre nourricière du
la nature reprend un petit peu ses
droits et les pieds parce que le travail
des agriculteurs ont également il ya
peut-être aller à peine 2 mois de ça on
trouvait à peine quelques chi quelques
racines en faire ce qu'ils avaient été
protégés dans tout le reste c'était nul
et là avec plaisir on revoit sa part il
converse tournante en carotte
voilà la diversité ça fait
[Musique]
il ya un lien spécial il n'y a pas de
danger il n'y a pas de produits jt pas
naturel
salut de 21 à l'éveil il va faire un
gros coup de fatigue au volant comme
celle qui a pas beaucoup d'eau - qui
était un tout petit mieux dans 10 salles
et de la basse terre la terre les plus
riches alors qu'agen impôts qu il ya au
sein de l'élite
les aviculteurs guadeloupéens ont
conscience de posséder une terre
exceptionnel même emmanuelle qui n'a que
17 ans et passionnée par son terroir
nous avons une terre riche en minéraux
grâce au volcan qui produisent de la
sangle du magma et il sauve qui sont des
éléments essentiels à la production de
nutriments pour les plantes et c'est ce
qu'ils font que nous avons des produits
de qualité sinon qui m'a pratiquement
l'enseigné sur l'agout transformation du
manioc et tout ce que je sers beaucoup
de l'agriculture et de la culture
guadeloupéenne
en fait la science du vivant je dirais
m'a toujours passionné de savoir comment
les choses vivent comment elle
fonctionne ça m'a toujours passionné et
en faire mon métier ce serait un rêve
puisque pour moi quand on travaille dans
ça on est vraiment et panis est en
symbiose avec soi même
maintenant parlons
[Musique]
les heures sur le stand d'à côté rien de
comestible à première vue le clanche
médicinales sont ici manipuler avec soin
oui
[Musique]
lucien sabban on connaît tous les
secrets vous avez les chambres nous
avons réparé avant les maisons étaient
construites en bois et en tôles leur
plaie en manipulant pour se glisser les
charpentiers show de l'essai et pour un
petit peu cicatriser la blessure on
parle on passe à septembre
donc c'est un cicatrisant je vais aussi
vous parler de la chronique alors qu'on
sonne comme son nom au sud consolidation
des tissus sains jouer au football on
n'avait pas de chaussures on avait
souvent des intenses le soir je pars en
prenne plein à 4 avril et le lendemain
matin réveil nickel si vous avez aussi
perdu la voix
vous pouvez faire une incision de consul
ça va régénérer les tissus qui ont été
abîmés
j'aime les endroits humides meilleur du
soleil ce qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde
s'intéresse aux plantes médicinales
tout le monde veut avoir son petit
jardin tout le monde veut avoir quelques
petites plantes médicinales même s'ils
n'ont pas au mondial optimhome terre les
plantes peuvent se cultiver en pot
[Musique]
on
en guadeloupe le succès des plantes
médicinales et une au travail d'un homme
il cultive en contrebas de la soufrière
un jardin extraordinaire véritable
conservatoire de ce patrimoine végétal
[Musique]
qu'en fait ce n'est pas soit soufflé
hier il travaille avec le plus jeune
défenseur plan de vol du peu de cas
qu'ils étudient les organismes peuvent
avoir des propriétés médicamenteuse
[Musique]
alors ça c'est de la miss
alors quand on parle de duy l'essentiel
il faut employer le thème h e bay dans
son jardin contraire la végétation
luxuriante qui prend un seul dans les
sols volcaniques système nerveux et donc
il suffit de toucher à vous toucher
par exemple ici l'extrémité sud a fait
il ya un influent qu'il va continuer et
qu'il va donc voilà entraîné la
fermeture de toutes les autres alors mes
sensitive marie enfin pudica et moselle
big sister les pudiques
ces plantes qu'on appelle le 3 tasses
trois tasses une tasse le matin tu as
remis d'une tasse le soir
en fait c'est une plante qui possèdent
des propriétés intéressantes c'est à
diminuer la cholestérolémie tout
cholestérol mais surtout c'est un
excellent c'est latif les gens qui ont
du mal à dormir
et c'est un carminati donc ça permet de
bien digérer
donc vous voyez tout cela se retrouve
dans notre jardin
[Musique]
c'est la biodiversité peut-être
ordinaire chez légumineuses qui
s'appelle le bois n'a pas mal et puis
c'est ce qu'une plante qui est utilisé
pour redonner la virginité au pain ça
resserre valway mais les américains on
appuie cet usage oui et ils ont inventé
un médicament qui s'appelle ces petits
cons l'équipe le sceptique on est là
c'est pourquoi en fait et est utilisé en
fait pour resserrer les un petit peu la
gencive
quand les gens ils ont justement des
cancers de la bouche
[Musique]
le docteur henri joseph est reconnu pour
son travail et ses idées il a même été
élu plusieurs fois personnalité de
l'année en guadeloupe pendant plus de 15
ans il s'est battu pour faire inscrire
une plante tropicale dans la pharmacopée
française
je suis pharmacien je suis dans mon
officine
je suis condamné avant-hier camomille
verveine bordeaux quand des plantes dans
la métropole ça vous aurait pas tout
chez vous moi ça me touche comme moi
j'ai des plantes dans mon jardin et que
la loi dit que pour qu'une plante us est
vendu dans une pharmacie française alors
qu'il me semble bien que ma pharmacie et
une pharmacie française et que j'ai le
droit devant les plantes de marseille
les vendre les plantes de nice de la
côte d'azur et c est moi j'ai pas le
droit de vendre des plantes de la
guadeloupe mais moi j'ai dit non mes
deux premiers à qui ces plantes
interdites depuis l'époque de la
colonisation étaient considérés comme
impropres à usage médical
les colons ayant une peur ils ont pondu
un arrêté du 1799 qui disait quoi il est
interdit aux gens de couleur noire
esclave d'exercer la médecine la
chirurgie d'utiliser aucun remède sous
quelle forme que ce soit sous peine de
seyssins fondamente pour les gens qui
sont libres punition corporelle pour les
esclaves et les colons qui tolère ce
type de pratiques seront déchus de leur
disais cela parce que il est vrai à
savoir faire connaissait les plantes et
leurs propriétés et l'hiver soigner
pouvait aussi empoisonné il pourrait
faire tout cela et il fallait contrôler
tous ces gens là et c'est pour ça que
nous plante ne se retrouvait pas la
pharmacopée française parce qu'on est
devenue département français en 1946
mais il ya eu jamais il n'y a jamais eu
la vocation en fait au bout de douze ans
de bataille juridique le gouvernement a
compris et on a réussi à modifier
l'article est 7100 12-1 du code de la
santé publique qui disait dans son
ancien article que la pharmacopée
comprend la pharmacopée française et
européenne points nous on a fait mettre
virgule y compris celle de l'outre-mer
français
et le combat n'est pas près de s'arrêter
plus de 625 plantes médicinales sont
répertoriés en guadeloupe
et seulement 62 sont pour l'instant
inscrite dans la pharmacopée française
un autre endroit sur l'archipel
bénéficie lui aussi des bienfaits du
volcan
[Musique]
direction morne-à-l'eau sur l'île de
grande terre
mythe ou réalité l'audit on y serait
miraculeuse
[Musique]
à 35 km de son cratère au gré des vents
et des courants
les cendres rejetées par la soufrière se
déposent dans sept ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mélanger à l'argile elle forme une goût
qu'on s'applique sur le corps une
balnéothérapie des plus naturelles
[Musique]
je suis réclamiez jeune âge certains
pour ne pas dire no 16
[Musique]
le médecine et coll
on ne roule pas et quelquefois quand on
vole trop 6
plutôt avec les parents j'étais
un peu au chant j'ai fait des fautes et
je jouais devront japonais beaucoup de
coups
[Musique]
alors bon
et ma profession mais ben j'étais
professeur de sport continue le full
tilt est souvent debout sous la charme
en train de me déplacer
il y eut ensuite un recours une fois tu
du plateau tibial et le chirurgien m'a
dit que je devais mettre une prothèse
sinon je serais amené à circuler en
chaise roulante
j'ai une cousine qui émeut voix pour ne
pas salir à côté de ma voiture est dit
qu est-ce qui a tout à fait conduire lui
dit non je n'arrive pas à poser le pied
par terre parce que l'image en défaut au
centre hospitalier pour enlever des avec
derrière les épines calcaire il dit
c'est pas vrai tapez encore mal sinon je
serais allé voir le dr bad jeudi docteur
bader y dit oui le gabon at il pas le
monde à l'autre dit que ces bons à rien
n'était pas le montant low-kick ne
connais pas le docteur je commence à
énumérer et docteur de mon à l'eau parce
que je les connais tous mais me dire je
t'ai pas parler le médecin s'était pas
les par les docteurs c'est pas la peine
de prendre des rendez-vous tu fais
tomber tes vêtements et tourne dans son
cabinet
tu a patiné supporter en maillot de bain
et pointer du doigt les talibans tombait
à son rythme eric entame sa séance de
balnéothérapie dans cette eau surnommé
dr baba 7 à une quinzaine de mètres du
rivage que se trouve le précieux remède
qu'on vient chercher de loin je vous la
voyez vous le disais les plaques les
petites blagues bref selon les dires des
gens des plus anciennes moi ce sont des
plaques de soufre donc voir elle est
vraiment une tueuse comme la facile
[Musique]
durant plusieurs semaines chaque matin
eric est venu rendre visite à ceux
d'auteurs si particulier
[Musique]
aussi
assis sur son rocher
pour lui le rituel est toujours le même
il s'enduit des genoux jusqu'aux
chevilles
[Musique]
exactement un mois et trois semaines
après le passé le contrôle si les
fougères
il m'a dit monsieur amis continuer à
faire ce que vous faites vous avez parlé
de bouteille c'est plus l'actualité et
si vous avez mal un jour vous m'appelez
[Applaudissements]
il y a quelques mois
eric est arrivé en rampant sur cette
plage aujourd'hui à sa manière il fait
son footing dans l'eau ces bambins jeu
comme ça a été efficace je dis bien
c'est bien l'auteur
[Musique]
reste encore à faire reconnaître les
vertus de seydou par le corps médical
[Musique]
protéger les bienfaits du volcan faire
évoluer les mentalités
c'est l'émission du dr henry joseph ça
c'est un cordial au pardon retour à
basse terre dans son jardin d'éden
l'abri de toutes ces recherches
et en plus c'est très marrant après cela
sur la échoué c'est parce qu'on a
toujours voulu faire des grands entre à
huy où il avait des gants troupes
allaient chercher de l'or des diamants
aujourd'hui les incas les mayas les
égyptiens c'est isation n'existe plus
ensuite on a fait des grands trous pour
aller chercher du pétrole
ça a donné quoi s'adonner naguère
sadouni la famine ça donnait les
attentats ça donne tout ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui rup sion la corruption etc
etc
et ça donne surtout tous mes amis qui
sont par terre avec maria et omaha et
tout ça heureusement la 2g bâti alors
moi ce que je te conseille jeudi l'a
convaincu mais je veux quand même temps
à moi je suis tout vu tu vois tu vois tu
prends cet index la wii
juste deux phalanges j'ai une voix et tu
fais juste mon petit tout d'accord avec
deux phalanges tu prends une petite
graine tu mets dedans mais ça te donne
ça donc ça fait un trou quand même un
tout petit trou doit savoir faire
internet en disant tu vas comprendre que
pour sauver la planète il faut faire des
petites routes inondées grand trou c'est
le gouffre la course tu vas tomber
dedans
moi je fais toutes les épices
là tu voyais à cannes elle a week end ce
fut banni je fais un jean je fais même
de la cardamome
c'est à dire mais top tout laisse à eau
en fait on leur accorde un moment tout
simplement dans une dans une épicerie et
à planter
j'ai plein de talent
[Rires]
laissez vivre cette nature tout en la
protégeant c'est le défi de demain dans
son jardin henry fait figure de
visionnaire
ici bien sûr aucun pesticide tout est
recyclé rien ne se perd
[Musique]
donc je quand j'ai fait mon indigo
comme c'est une plante qui riche en
azote je le mets dans les champs et ça
me ça me permet de redonner de la zone
taux plein qui font pas de la zot tout
fait du compost c'est le must
oui mais ça c'est un complot dirigé
trouver riche en azote
voilà voilà d'accord la petite odeur
voilà tu sens la fermentation et
l'ammoniac
tu sais on regarde mais je sentis tue
l'amour oui voilà l'ammoniaque bien cela
[Rires]
là tu vois tous les déchets sont mis ici
et c'est on a fait du compost
rien ne se perd rien ne se crée tout se
transforme et quand vous regarder dedans
regardez commence à boire de la vie qui
est dedans la vie qui dans mon
composteur
regardez comment sa bouche donc s'il y
avait le moins de pesticides y aurait
pas toute cette vie là et moi je crains
la vie à partir de la vie
vidéo
tout se fait sans nous en fait moi tu
vois la montagne qu'il a cette montagne
a pas d'homme il ya pas de pesticides
il n'y a pas d'abus s'il n'ya pas
d'engrais pour moi 150 mètres plus bas
je dois obligatoirement faire vivre les
producteurs de pesticides nous on en a
pas besoin
on n'a pas besoin d'un herbicide on n'a
pas besoin d'engrais
on n'a pas besoin de pesticides c'est de
l'agro écologie et ça s'appelle de la
gouaille ecology ou écologie et moi je
fais plus que l'agro écologie je fais de
l'économie sémiotique tout est en
symbiose
quand je t'ai dit que je fais de
l'économie symbiotique regarde cette
petite abeille
regarde là là là voilà l'ennemi examen
l'opsis marche i way qui fait compte de
façon qui pollinisent pardon de façon
spécifiquement indigo ah oui vous me
donnez des gones d'indigo qui va me
permettre de faire le show me donc si
moi je tue sept petites abeilles en
mettant des pesticides
j'aurais pas légaux oui donc tu vois on
regarde comment ils travaillent pour moi
je regarde là il est en train de
coloniser chaque fleur qu et regarde ce
que j'ai fait comme association leur
applique ici si tu goûtes tu verras
c'est très amer d'accord oui c'est très
amer
et puisque c'est amer leshan il vient de
partout dans
alors que les chenilles les chenilles
peuvent dernière mais sczesny peuvent
venir sur indigo à la main ces trois
mères voilà voilà donc la leude il
regarde le deal à l'est par le biais des
mycorhizes tu m'envoies de la zot dessus
ça zot et confèrent des feuilles puisque
les chenilles mangent des feuilles
je venais repoussé donc échange de bons
procédés
il faut de mettre la pression regarde
regarde comment on fait l'éloge en fait
sans même pas j'ai fait une coupe à il
ya même pas trois mois mais au sol aux
citoyens de légumineuses ou sur wii voir
ces plantes couvre-sol il empêche les
mauvaises herbes de pousser 20 cm voilà
et comme c'est une légumineuse qu'est ce
que ça fait ça vient aider l'indigo a
donné en fait de la zot hasmonéens
rapide clé donc tout va bien une
croissance rapide
il n'y a pas de vrai j'en ai argent
merde j'en ai joué au sol
jameer ben oui
pour ces deux passionnés de botanique
des richesses naturelles de la
guadeloupe sont une source de création
inépuisable
ensemble ils ont pour ambition de
transmettre cette passion au plus grand
nombre
[Musique]
la soufrière est à la fois un volcan
jeunes dangereux bouillonnant et une
vieille dame généreuse vénéré par les
guadeloupéens
mais
il accepte le risque de vivre à ses
pieds car ses bienfaits sont des trésors
inestimables
[Musique]
m
à
[Musique]